Hello CZsWorld, and welcome to the first episode of a new web-series called True Fear.
In this web-series I'm going to be stepping outside the world of fiction to talk about some real life scary stories that have happened in the world,
and I know that they're true because they've personally happened to me.
This episode will detail my late night run in with a creepy urban sleepwalker.
...or at least that's what I thought was going on.
Here's how it went down.
So it started when I was on my way home from my girlfriend at the time's house.
She was going to visit family that weekend so I went up one last time to visit her before she left.
So basically I ended up walking home pretty late at night.
And also, this is not the best neighborhood. I've heard gunshots and apparently there's a meth issue.
So I'm crossing the last intersection to get back to my apartment and there's just this guy standing there at the corner.
This guy had dark skin, he was wearing a dress shirt, he had a tie on, he had a messenger bag over his shoulder.
He was wearing black pants and he was just a pretty tall and intimidating figure.
I'm waiting for the light and I'm standing perpendicular to where he's standing.
The light changes and he doesn't move.
I'm getting kind of nervous because I have to cross over this way and basically cross in front of him to get back to my apartment.
So all this stuff is going through my head, I'm thinking:
Is this guy going to mug me? Is he mentally ill? Is he insane?
It looks like he's just standing there waiting for me.
So I cross the street, and as I get closer to him, I fell like he's going to say something to me.
I try not to make eye contact but I just get this feeling that he's just going to reach out and grab me or something.
As I cross in front of him I steal a glance and I notice that his eyes are just closed.
So I'm walking back to my apartment and I'm thinking, "what's going on with that guy?"
"That's pretty creepy that he's just standing there with his eyes closed."
And the idea that he was sleepwalking hadn't really come to me yet.
I honestly just thought he was kind of a weirdo at this point.
As I get to my apartment I'm just thinking more and more about how weird that whole situation was.
I want to go and get some video evidence of it but I kind of doubt that the guy's still standing out there after quite a few minutes.
So I grab my roommate who is also into mysterious things, tell him about the situation, and we go to check it out.
Sure enough, the guy has not moved whatsoever.
So we get out there, we're behind him now, about 50 feet away.
And it's just quiet. It's 2 in the morning. There are no people out. There are no cars out.
We're keeping our voices down low so that he doesn't hear us if he is awake.
As we're debating whether or not to get closer, I snap a quick photo and video.
Now it's pretty far away, it's not the best evidence and it's at night so it's a little bit hard to see.
But the figure is just really creepy standing there at the end of the corner and it's the only evidence that I have from that night.
So finally we decide, OK, we'll just walk forward, walk past him, see what happens. Check things out.
And as we get closer, the guy just drops.
And he catches himself with his left leg.
And he's almost in this stretching position like he's lunging to the left.
He gets to that position; and we just freeze, we're like, "OK, what's going on here?"
Then he proceeds to stick in that position for quite a while longer.
We're not exactly sure what to do.
And I know I should have gotten another picture at this part, but I honestly felt like this guy was going to turn around at any point.
So finally, we're waiting around a little bit, he doesn't do anything, and we decide to get closer again.
And as we're walking up to him, he stands up, looks around, seems kind of confused, and then just starts walking forward across the street and disappears into the night.
We don't bother following him because at this point we figured whatever was going on with him,  he'd snapped out of it, he's woken up.
So this is when we came to the consensus that maybe he was sleepwalking.
Maybe we was just walking home from his second job or something...
He was really tired. Got to the stop light. Closed his eyes and fell asleep standing up for a few minutes.
Or maybe he was just sleeping in his apartment and started sleepwalking all the way out to the street and just stopped there.
Though... that doesn't really explain the attire he was wearing.
I contacted my old roommate recently to see if he had any recollections about the night,
and he suggested that it may have been drugs, and looking back on it, I think that's kind of a theory that makes sense.
Leave your theory in the comments though!
But what's really scary to me is to think about what could have been.
For example, what if this guy had stopped walking a few feet forward and just stopped in the middle of the street?
Or what if he really was mentally ill and dangerous and I just happened to walk by when his eyes were closed?
Or what if he was sleepwalking and he would have walked by right when I was going by and freaked out?
Who knows what would have happened to me?
So I was really interested in this and for a few nights after that I went out around the same time to check and see if he was there.
To see if this was like a common habit that maybe he's sleepwalking at the same time every night.
But I never saw him out there again.
I did, however, see other things... which were perhaps more scary.
Which I'll talk about in the next episode of True Fear, so subscribe if you have not already.
Also, special shoutout to my buddy WestDakota for helping me film this video.
Go check out his channel, he does daily vlogs.
But like, don't just not check it out, actually go check it out.
Dakota: Click right here on my face.
Get out of here.
If you liked this video, remember to like this video, and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.